hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to be nkr also known as
bunker if you want an Alan and a lamb a
legend and eyes like that it's called by
you guys resources are running out and
every year
survival becomes more difficult many of
us went offline already 10 years ago
nothing was happening here that's so sad
why 10 years ago was nothing for a long
time maybe intriguing so anyway this
game is actually really interesting
because it's about androids there at the
end of the world and they need to find
stuff to survive oh yeah nothing in scam
is gonna be funny is gonna be depressing
and have no money I've known Oh with a
sale nevermind I didn't even know I was
clicking on there well what are we up
here in this town that's the bumper of
their tendon why who's a superintendent
why do you have a superintendent what is
that that I can click on over there is
their mysteries it
thank you know what this is for
well I don't know what anything's for
why are you sassing me oh hey hello
yes Android comrade I've heard the
screeching yes you get inside there
might be something valuable there take
this broken key I found it by the bunk
Thank You captain exposition thank you
for moving the story forward so that I
can progress okay instructions for a
laundry machine it's important
oh so important why why is it important
to waste my batteries but I just want to
hang out with you I want to be your
friend seems human probably not do a
switch okay okay cool there are the
things that are thrown Z over here nice
answers everyone let me get out of here
how do I go home oh exactly like that
how every other game I would go on
nevermind I'm a dumb-dumb yes carnival
costumes exactly what that was
they popped out and surprise kids with
gas that's morbid
why I thought you're a super-strong
Android what's wrong with you alright
fine new ok I have no money you don't
need money here
oh the bicycle oh okay is that a portal
turret right there I think that might be
Oh who's gonna kill me something missing
well I don't know just being a now
regular oh my god Mac a national myth
simple Android I wouldn't know anything
of a way but I flipped the flu B flapper
I thought the light was gonna ping-pong
and then it was gonna go on why does
nothing work here well isn't that just a
shortcoming of yourself but we all have
shortcomings so don't talk to me about
indentation
maybe it's an elevator nothing you'd
know about that I seem to be pushing on
two buttons
oh I have switches here oh okay won't do
it until I find them all got it okay so
that doesn't work
but this does hmm but it might open with
this Oh half of a key house half cookie
gonna help me it's a little dark okay so
do I need to did I get all them there
they're there oh squeeze throw your
skinny come on oh don't you now but
dancing is life oh you're not alive just
a poor little Android why don't you
leave a balloon markiplier
ah yeah you're absolutely right
congratulations you win a prize of
nothing it's long is it though something
is missing here I'm gonna shove that up
my button then I'm gonna get all the
energy that's now I might become that
but also might not become that so you
know there's that I mean if this weird
and wall is just gonna all set
mysteriously vanish and not vanish I'm
going to be enamored with what might
kill me in here okay so what I figure is
I must have missed a switch out here
because there's got to be something else
around here that I cannot see they sure
did their robot friend they sure did I
like this game I like this guy he's got
sense of humor even though he's not
really a guy I mean I was using my giant
brain to solve all these puzzles here so
with this I'll be able to do a thing but
it's broken so I got to figure out a fix
there was duct tape in the other place
there was duct tape I know right there
can I please know
I thought I was on to something damn it
Oh sir
broken key do some ballot maybe help me
out here Oh your batteries always just a
simple fact for all of you again you
were wondering Anna
Android's don't have beams did I say
animals are androids annals definitely
do that penises people send me a lot of
them in my email don't stem no god no
this is gonna be an endless flood thank
you very much markiplier god dammit stop
baby problems for yourself I didn't even
know that was a knock did but I did it I
got that now what do I do
I know age I knew what I could do I can
go here like it BAM oh so you're vain oh
yeah you like looking at yourself where
you are damn handsome Android but that
doesn't mean you can beat up your own
ass if you have an ass I apologize all
Android viewers out there really I'm
sorry that I'm such an idiot
oh that was open that was open this
whole time
it is something open it very creepy but
I don't know if androids have fear so
I'll have a fear enough for everybody
Sanders just like me but what about me I
need that delicious energy definitely
keep it until after immediately why
don't you want to open it come on
there could be goodies in there so that
was the last do daddy over there and
then I have all the switches for here
OOP yes it worked I'm a genius robot are
there even genius robots I'm not
entirely sure but so far
does that mean the light is on maybe yes
okay let me see what this giant dildo
switch does nothing exactly what I was
hoping for how about in here is closed
no kidding thank you very much for
pointing out the obvious I wanted you to
open it oh thank you you're not any help
at all so what did that last buzzer do
cuz that was the last lighter duty oh
yeah no King thank you
this game is like oddly creepy in a
weird way and I don't even know if it's
like fully intended to be any sort of
horrifying this is either we don't have
fires being robots or whatever important
device how do you know you don't know
anything I guess okay so cool you were
just telling me it was important so I'd
actually tried to do something with it
okay some parts I'm using here I need to
find yes almost it's drugs it's pure
drugs and they love drugs those humans
they sure do this is something there is
something there why don't you look at it
thank you very much
orange Yujin okay so this door I can
open yes and there's nothing creepy in
here there's kerosene who used it who
could have possibly use
become useful yes just random handle
I'll just stuff that in my Robo pockets
oh boy a robo box cutter
are those Robo boho phones what I meant
to say robo headphones but my stupid
brain didn't make the words come out
good of my mouth haha okay so I did that
anything else here that I would possibly
need paper knife okay how can you smell
your dad do you have smell input devices
also known as a no who's an Android nose
a robo Bono's a ronin Oh Robo nose I
know Robin if that dumb manobo would
know but knows okay so armed with my
Robo Bono's I'm going to go somewhere
and cut open a box
it's sad explicitly there was something
here huh yes it said that for a reason
oh I got a handle I've always wanted to
get a handle on my life because it's in
utter chaos
my hair's getting to that point again
starting to get a little floofy I gotta
cut it more proactively again okay so if
I have a handle is there something on
this that yes am I out of energy Adam
probably about to die or something the
mirror maybe I have an idea and I don't
know if it's gonna be I don't know if
it's gonna be problematic it worked but
do I want to go down there yet the
mirror pieces like it's obviously to see
my reflection maybe I'm a look in the
mirror and I'm not gonna see a Ruben
didn't Borden code I don't know where to
get a code because I'm a big dumb dumb
rapper every River
oh you're noises by the way your noises
hello it wasn't what I was looking for
buddy what's that
you guys hear that use me
okay so anyway yes now don't look at
myself and help you oh hey
okay that's 1961 or one six nine one or
one nine six one oh my god what if it's
upside down okay either one nine six one
okay oh I'm so pretty and creepy looking
like I know this game is probably not
meant to be disturbing but it's one one
I know how to count
well lookie Lewis that I must be special
like wall-e and TV who could've killed
an Android
to be continued that was really good
those really intriguing it was a world
unlike I've ever seen oh I'm so cool I
was awesome I wonder who this I don't
know if there's another part yet I
didn't see another part I just only saw
this one but either way this was really
really fun this is really interesting
and it was weird to see the whole world
from a perspective of an Android so let
me know what you think in the comments
below thank you for the suggestion I'll
try to fit in the future write the names
of the people who suggest but a lot of
people suggest the game game so thank
you for the suggestions in if you have
any other games you'd like me to play in
the future
let me know the comment below thanks
again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video